quand un excès de bonne volonté tourne
mal c'est un peu l'histoire de l'espoir
de sainte luce le club devait emmener
l'équipe féminine et l'équipe masculine
au challenge ultramarins qui débute
mercredi prochain à paris les billets
d'avion devaient être payés par la ctm
mais au final aventure parisienne
s'annonce très compliquée et nécessaire
n'a pas été fait en temps et en heure
vis-à-vis du quota de billets attribués
pour la cpmc bien que l'on retrouve
actuellement une situation où il n'y a
pas de place pour voyager donc nous
sommes neuf actuellement à paris sur le
côté a pris en charge par le club
nous avons pu voyager il y a quatre
filles et quatre garçons et moi en tant
que chef de la délégation et nous ne
sommes pas là effectivement mardi après
midi voire bien au petit matin au moins
six personnes
et maintenant on fait donc c'est une
année de travail qui vit tentions en
fumée et je vous le rappelle sur les six
champions des autres maires donc ça
risque de faire à des désordres que la
matinée que ne soient pas représentés à
la compétition des douze couverts
le 3 mai dernier le conseil exécutif de
la ctm a effectivement accordé 22
billets d'avion à l'espoir de saint plus
mais tout s'est compliqué dès le stade
de la réservation des billets
normalement du ressort de la ctm et ce
point de sainte luce a fait une
réservation ce qui a bloqué des certain
nombre de sièges et la 7e n'a pas pu
intervenir
voici pourquoi les billets sont tombés
faute de règlement
nous essayons de rattraper le coup nous
faisons tout aucun les sportifs et les
volleyeurs qui sont méritants puisse
défendre les couleurs de la martinique
et de l'espoir de ses puces
depuis 8h ce matin le club et la ctm et
c'est d'accorder leurs violons pour
permettre à l'espoir de représenter la
martinique ou challenge ultramarins 13
joueurs sont déjà partis via la guyane
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]